et on prend la direction de l'italie le
pays tente de profiter de la crise du
coronavirus pour modifier profondément
son administration le premier ministre
ghiz étaient comptés a présenté un
projet de réforme devant le parlement
l'objectif est de simplifier la
bureaucratie
cette réforme devrait permettre de
rendre le pays plus compétitif et
transparent en limitant aussi à
l'infiltration de la mafia au coeur des
organismes publics
un projet jugé essentiel par guiseppe
comptait relancer l'économie du pays
nous travaillons sur le nouveau décret
loi consacré à la simplification
administrative et bureaucratique qui
introduira plusieurs nouveaux éléments
afin de fournir à l'italie un choc
économique sans précédent en particulier
dans le secteur des infrastructures
je considère cette réforme comme la mère
de toutes les réformes
la seule capable de stimuler
efficacement la compétitivité de notre
pays
l'italie ne peut plus attendre au
tournant si nous ne parvenons pas à
simplifier maintenant dans cet état
d'urgence absolue
je doute franchement que nous pourrons
le faire à l'avenir